Bam, there you go.
April Fool's.
Wow.
No joke, I'm joking.
I'm joking.
You guys know this is anything different?
The chat's different.
April Fool's.
But we're here for serious business today.
We have a real swimsuit reveal coming up.
You must be thinking, wow, Doki.
Wow.
Where's the swimsuit?
It's real.
just building up the anticipation for it guys do not and i
have to show you guys the predictions i didn't realize a lot
of you guys were submitting some predictions of what the
swimsuit would look like and i'll give us some love to it as
well before we go straight to the reveal that's right chat's
different april fools and we're gonna be doing a reveal a
new outfit reveal on this very normal day of the first of
april uh so it's prediction time prediction tab of what the
swimsuit could look like.
I'm super excited to show you guys this.
I know I could have waited.
Yeah, that's right.
Chat's different.
The old... That's right.
What a great joke.
I know.
Such a great joke.
I sure got you guys.
And honestly, it's because the chat overlay is broken.
So I'm trying to get that.
The chat overlay is broken.
I had to get a replacement.
But, look at that.
I'm so wild and quirky.
Jokes on you.
I just wanted to hear you.
Yeah, Tom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, guys, I received the skin suit.
I think, like, what was it, two days ago?
And I was like, do I wait to reveal this?
Do I just rip it, you know, like I've got a little too
excited, you know, I was just like, oh, fuck it, let's just
drop it, drop it now, um, I have nothing to do for this week
anyway, so might as well give you guys a little freebie,
give you some guys some excitement for the start of April,
uh, this could have been an email toky, say, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, so, um, so that's why we're here,
Oh, yeah, we drop it like it's hot.
It's time to solve the world's greatest mystery.
What is under that sports bra?
Finally, we're going to ask one of Dragon's greatest
mysteries in the Dokiverse.
What is underneath that sports bra?
Today, we're going to find out.
I swore on Dad's life.
that it is a real swimsuit reveal and people didn't believe
me i literally swore on dad's life that it was it is a
swimsuit reveal um one most highly anticipated outfits out
there wouldn't be funny it was just me like like glazing it
up and then i just keep glazing it and glazing it and then
the stream ends oh that would be so funny guys if that like
it's here right now right like like the like the the
crocodile teeth thing is like oh please like and subscribe
and i'm gonna press that button right now i'm gonna press it
right now guys remember remember to like and subscribe and
i'll reveal the outfit very soon so soon i'm gonna reveal it
right now right now in 10 seconds 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2
remember to pull up the stream right here like it like and
subscribe guys like and subscribe everybody oh i'm so scared
i'm so i'm i'm shaking in anticipation on revealing this
outfit.
Oh, whoa.
But no, there is a real outfit, guys.
There is a real bikini or swimsuit.
Sorry, swimsuit.
Oh, oh, oopsie.
Did I?
Whoops.
Did I accidentally leak something?
Oh, no, it's just a regular swimwear.
Oh,
Hold, hold on.
Patch arrested.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Rest in peace, my homie.
Dad, he got snatched by a Paw Patrol after this stream.
Doki said on his life.
Mighty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Honestly, there's not going to be a lot of sports.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
you Alan thank you for the super chat thank you thank you my
oh she has given me trust issue anyway let's get on to right
to it and by right to it I mean showing the predictions so
as y'all know I showed you guys let's see where is it this I
was very surprised that we got a couple of entries for this
because I did you know it was like you know I hot dropped it
uh like without with a They didn't really give a lot of time
for people.
So thank you to all the artists for their amazing
predictions for this outfit.
Where is it?
There it is.
Thank you to all the artists for giving us predictions on
the swimwear, the most highly anticipated Doki Bird outfit
of all time.
uh very thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
that jingle jangle is a lie there's an inflation device
underneath that bra like how he like dropped that super chat
in like in like in the future i had to predict the future
all right so i actually am saving the predictions live i
woke up at 4 p.m again today uh i'm not very proud of that
um i i do need to fix it eventually just a lot of stuff has
been going on a lot of work stuff and also a lot of
overwatcher i need to stop i need i do need to stop guys i
will stop eventually anyway so we got this one our first
prediction she thinks i'm holding uh this is from sleepy or
pixel noodles um she thinks uh i am holding some big
tomatoes that i guess that would be the april fools joke no
joke here.
There's no joke here.
I'm not holding anything.
I'm just gonna let you guys know that.
But it is very cute.
I love how you utilize the little tomato on the top right.
That's the little bump on the head.
And the little swimsuit and the little and the feather there
as well.
And you know, get those toes Oh,
I am holding something, but it's not tomatoes.
Oops, did I say too much?
Oh, did I say a little too much there, guys?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, I did not mean to let that slip out.
Betty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Everyone doubted me for believing in your swimsuit, but they
will repent when the outfit is released.
Don't worry, Medi, they will all regret this for doubting
us.
I don't understand why no one believes me.
Maybe that's the joke all along.
I make it so, I make it like, make it seem like it's a joke,
but it wasn't.
You're like, wow, Doki, you're acting it.
so it's so bad right now or maybe that was the act all along
there's layers and layers to this is she telling the truth
is she telling a lie what if everything i said was the truth
all along but then you just don't believe me that's on you
for not believing in me it's all there in front of you yet
somehow you're not picking up the hints at all It was all in
front of you all this time Anyway, next prediction I even
gave you a fucking silhouette And yet somehow people are
like Don't, like It's a fucking silhouette What do you want
from me?
Laughy, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you We
are all living Oh, the suspense, the anticipation of
everything maybe the april fools is making guys so paranoid
but it's it was real all along or maybe you guys are right
and there is no swimwear but i did swear on dad's life that
there is so so is she just like is she just gonna like keep
stalling and stalling and there's gonna be two hours and
we're still here with no swimwear but you gotta watch and
find out dragons where when does this end when is she gonna
show us oh you gotta watch and find out mr.
broken fine thank you thank you thank you stop catless
lighting us i'm already in an insane asylum thank you the
super chat thank you thank you oh this one this one is from
candy buns and they went watch hour so so if you guys have
never watched bay watch like me um this is the iconic
lifeguard switch yeah that those are definitely that there's
no sports bra there uh fake news hey it's all it's a
prediction guys they're all predictions um it could be any
one of them um oh thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you you're worse than a cheater you're alive live
pants on fire let me cry thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you i didn't lie i told you i there is a swimsuit
it's a real swimsuit reveal i didn't lie about anything i
don't understand i don't understand why nobody believes me
on this normal day of april it's the start of april in me
it's the in between a spring and summer and it's the start
of the of the cherry to celebrate that guys i just couldn't
wait any longer to reveal this outfit i was like i know i
was just like oh they won't expect this outfit out of me and
they were right nobody expected this i just it just was
unfortunate timing that it coincided with april 1st it was
just the coincidence guys there is a real swimsuit reveal
and i don't know why none of you guys believe me i mean
kitty on april 1st i do feed you guys i you guys would have
never expected a a a cat skin suit yet you got a cat skin
suit on april 1st so why wouldn't you think i would give you
a swimsuit skin suit as well you feed me more i for one.
I'm a snake of faith.
You wouldn't lie to us.
Do you solid?
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Patch your rest, too.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
For no reason, I must randomly say that now would be a
terrible time for me to buy a pre-order swimsuit from Doki
Merch.
Just a hunch.
Thank you, was a Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, wait, did it leak on Doki Merch?
Oh, shit.
Okay, it was supposed to come out after the reveal, but
like, oh shit, okay.
The thing you're holding is a swimsuit, is it?
Doki, thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Anyway, check out DokiBrich.com.
She's just saying stuff now, made you look.
made you look all right see i told you i told you guys it
could be anything
it's like shodinger's swimsuit all right next prediction oh
i like the oh i love the little it's that little hat oh my
god it's a little is that a little hat i like the little uh
hat that got there.
That is a nice, that is a nice swimsuit.
Uh, this is from Ambrose V Spade Up.
Uh, it's very cute.
I love the little water gun there too.
And the tail, the bird tail, and also, oh, it's a very cute
swimsuit design.
Oh my gosh.
I also think this is cuter than the one I have than the one
for the swimsuit reveal.
Whoa.
Uh, yeah, and we got a tail too.
I do like the little tiny hat on the top right it's a very
cute design element all right here's another one from uh
let's see uh yeah it is very very cute uh oh my god there's
so many actually was not anticipating so many predictions
you artists work so fast thank you so much guys for uh the
insane talent that you have uh for making this in just a day
uh zila thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all
right next prediction next is
this is this even water is this even aerodynamic and water
would i be able to swim a lap in that i like will it hold
together like that's my only issue regarding that i feel
like it seems to be like a bit falling apart and like i
don't know if that's YouTube friendly if I go into the water
there yeah with wait okay my phone is waterproof I heard I
hear iPhones are now waterproof I don't know if I want to
test that out though uh sure true I got the floaties though
I got aerodynamic in water um but oh wait is that like a
little oh is it like a dad's Sunglasses like ray bands.
I think that's those are like ray bands, but they're like
dad bands And then there's a little towel over there.
Uh, is this that you're nail polished in that mint swimsuit
curious?
Uh, thank you for the super chat.
Patreus, thank you.
Thank you.
I don't know you gotta ask Britt for that They designed the
swimsuit.
All right, next prediction.
Oh, this one's a cutie.
I'm just gonna save over that.
Oh, yeah, I guess, oh, you figured, okay, no, sorry, not
figured out, so, oh, oh, no spoilers yet, no spoilers, I, I
mean, I was gonna say, I was gonna say, I really love the
addition of the little flower on the top right, it's so
cute, like, like, a little height, like, a little flower,
like, clip, too, on the top right, um, Well, what do you
mean?
I didn't slip anything.
Nothing slipped out.
It was just, I was just saying that I love the little design
element on the top right with a little flower clip.
I think it's very cute.
And I think the swimsuit itself is super cute as well.
And then there's a little water gun, the little water gun
that they have there.
All right, this one from, oh wait, the other one was from
Taste Like Go.
Tastes like Coke.
That was one.
The next one.
The next.
Okay.
To be fair.
I'm a little bit worried if YouTube's going to strike this
channel after this.
And then especially when I show this artwork.
But this one is from Fah Mont.
Or the Twitter handle.
Mont Fah.
Wow.
Alrighty.
All right.
Oh, wow.
I also love how people were like, you're not wearing
anything in that silhouette.
It's so naked.
I'm like, it's a swimsuit.
It's, what did you expect from a swimsuit outfit?
Of course, there seems to be nothing on the shoulders or
like the waist.
suit i'm going to swim i'm swimming i i don't need extra
stuff to weigh me down when i'm in the water i gotta win the
race all right let's see oh yeah but the sunglasses uh the
sunglasses are super adorable um oh my god someone saved
that dragoon he's getting choked guys someone help him i've
taken him hostage we gotta save that man you guys are like
he doesn't need to see don't worry don't you i'll sacrifice
myself and take his place
Don't worry, I will make the decision to sacrifice myself to
take his place.
All right, let's see.
All right, what else?
What else?
Another prediction that we have here.
All right, let me see.
Let me open all of them up.
We did show this one.
think oh wait no i didn't i'm sorry i'm already lost track i
already oh this one now this one is beautiful i think this
one has to be my favorite prediction of all time i
it is actually a me tomato all along that that one was smart
i wish i thought of that guys i that would have been an
actual real april fool's joke but this one is actually not a
joke i'll i'll i'll let you guys know right now i'll let you
guys know right now because i know some of you guys are like
oh she's gonna she talked about this before where she was
just gonna put the tomato in a bikini and then like fool us
all i'll let i'll let you guys know it's not the tomato it's
not the tomato guys and that is not the april fools here
this is not april fools i'm getting right now and you're
like that's it she's joking she's bluffing look at her you
can see the smirk on it nope i'm gonna give it to you guys
straight it's actually the crow it's the crow with the i'll
give you guys i'll let you guys know right now it's not
tomato in the bikini or what if that's the fake out all
along it was the tomato in the bikini all along what
so and i'll let you guys know it is a great idea i wish i
had that idea where i just put the tomato there like it was
just that all along uh uh me thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you cannot wait for the dump tomato key
reveal that is too obvious by the way You know, I already
talked about it.
Be like, oh, guys, wouldn't it be funny if it was just a
tomato and a bikini?
And I'll be like, oh, it's a super sexy dokey update.
And then bam, it's just a tomato and a bikini.
But I will let you know right now, that is not, that's just
too obvious.
You really think I'm such an amateur chat.
And you really think I am such an amateur to like let you
guys beforehand to spoil the entire joke but even before the
stream started guys that's not i'm ain't no amateur i yes
it's a tomato isn't it dokey
it's it guys it's 100
Doki, using reverse, using, so you're admitting it's in a
joke, but in advance, when I said I will reveal the tomato
in a bikini out of nowhere, there would be no like build up
to this, no setting up the tension, no anticipation on what
it could be, it just, bam, here it is, but that's just not
it, I gave you guys time.
I sent out the silhouette I was very serious that it is a
real swimsuit I was very serious on dad's life that this is
a real swimsuit and that like I'm taking this very seriously
uh dark thank you I'm doing it live dark thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you I have trust issue because of
you that's the fake out you're that's it I figured it out
that's the fake out guys this is it all Anyway, next
prediction.
Also, that one, the tomato one, was from Indy Zana.
Thank you for your great prediction.
The next one, the next prediction is from Grisacrim or
Kijara.
Thank you for your prediction.
Thank you.
Oh, I love the little hair bun, the little braided hair bun
on the top, right?
Oh, yeah, see?
that i am hold i told you i was holding something and it was
a tomato oh whoa did i oh sorry sorry ignore that ignore it
i'm ignoring that guys i didn't mean this guys that was just
a joke guys uh feel free to ignore it
oh my god someone help her carry all that weight
Stop spoiling it.
Leave it.
I want to leave it to my imagination.
Anyway, so here's another great prediction.
This one is a cheapy one.
Wait, oh my gosh, I accidentally deleted the tweet.
Give me a sec.
All right.
Let me find the tweet again.
Let me find the tweet again, guys.
uh It truly is a filler episode though.
It truly is It's like the length of a filler episode You
don't get anything until the very end But this one is from
cur vinery or Vire.
Thank you again for your prediction.
I left a little flower that you have on the on the hair And
a little tiny water gun.
And a little swimsuit design.
The classic like the X.
To hold it.
To hold.
You know.
Hold the baggage up.
It's a very.
Very cute design.
What else?
What other prediction.
Did I miss any other prediction?
Let me see.
There is one more.
Oh yeah.
This one.
I think this one was funny.
it's just straight up from what's that game again don't
start together it's just a spider that's the april fools
joke uh it's just oh my god she turned into a she turned
into a spider uh yeah i'm just gonna i'm just gonna boot up
over it's like after this overwatch game i'll reveal the
swimsuit um this is from elliot thank you for your
prediction i really appreciated Elliot yeah just right after
there I just put that's genius and then I'll be like all
right guys after I win a game in rivals too let me I'll
reveal the swimsuit um don't give her any ideas dragons
please I've been waiting for so long I didn't know how much
I needed until she fucking put up the waiting room um wow
thank you the super chat thank you thank you what of the one
piece yeah my i put the outfit right in the middle of the
ocean you gotta find it uh to reveal the swimsuit uh pumpkin
thank you the super chat thank you thank you um have a good
stream all right all right guys ready Guys, are you guys...
Are you guys ready?
Are you guys ready for the reveal?
No!
What if it's like the Metal Gear Solid game where it's like,
yeah, you're like, if everybody defused this nuke, you can
get this achievement, but then it will never happen because
everybody will always have nukes in the game.
And now I'm like, if everybody says yes.
no one else says no i will do the reveal if everyone can say
yes in 10 in 10 seconds and there's no one that says no nah
nah i'm fine and we're like in disagreement i will do the
reveal
because there's always gonna be one guy that will say no
just to be like i'm gonna ruin someone's today I mean all
right guys all right let's play a little game called who's
that dokey bird it's croaky who's that dokey bird it's dad
Who's that dokeybird?
It's Doakfield.
Mondays.
Who's that dokeybird?
It's Dokeybug.
It's Dokey Prime.
Who's that Doki Bird?
It's Doki!
It's Dragoons!
Who's that Doki Bird?
It's Retro Doki!
ceiling if you're ready dead who's that dokey bird
it's tomato dokey who's
that dokey bird it's
like what you see dragons yeah it's yay it's a Is this what
you want?
Hi!
Am I sexy?
Hello.
I am the new dokey in the dokeyverse.
I am sexy dokey.
Ha!
Oh my god.
That's why I was worried that YouTube was gonna bad me
because I mean, I have all the physics.
I am sexy doki am I not sexy enough for you guys wow give me
a sec oh you want to be closer look at that oh oh is it is
it the don't worry guys I'm very customizable watch this
it's okay guys wait wait wait wait wait give me a sec let me
figure Let me remember how to do this.
But don't worry, guys.
I can customize it.
Is this...
There you go.
Is this better?
Is this...
Is this better, you guys?
I can...
How about this?
How about...
Am I not sexy?
Am I not...
Wow!
Am I not sexy?
Yes, I'm sexy doki from the doki base.
I'm new here.
So, welcome to the beach.
I am sexy doki.
Do you like my swimsuit?
I made this myself.
I worked very hard sewing all of this.
together i know i that's why it's like it's made out of like
t-shirt fabric so that's why it's having a hard time holding
the package of it's it's made with pipe cleaners and fabric
so it's having a hard towel it would be a shame if it
slipped it would be a shame it's my it's the beach where you
guys talking about.
I'm at the beach right now.
I told you.
I told you it wasn't a lie.
It was a real swimsuit reveal.
I'm a dokey from the dokeyverse.
I told you it was not a tomato in a bikini.
It was a dokey in a tomato.
The pros of me must have been...
Oh, were you expecting something else, guys?
I don't understand.
Am I not good enough for you guys?
Is this not...
Is this not what you want?
Because... Because it can be bigger.
Is it...
Don't worry.
Is this... Is this what you want, guys?
Oh my gosh, I've been in, I'm so stupid, I didn't put on my
sunscreen, and now, oh no, I'm 10 now, oh, I got, oh, I'm
10, it would be a shame if I slip, everyone, oh,
Am I sexy enough, everyone?
What is that?
These were the love of God.
Certain parts of my navvies are very confused.
Other parts want the bleach treatment.
I don't understand.
I thought I was so sexy.
oh
this is an improvement and thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you you're still my favorite being even
though you are like this elliott thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I know what you want.
Let me just get rid of some extra weight there.
Please turn the RTX back on.
I'm going to go back and watch the view count drop.
Everyone.
I thought this was all this is what you guys wanted
everyone.
I don't understand.
I thought you guys all okay, I'll put my hair wig back on.
I'll put it back on.
I don't understand.
Is this you guys all wanted a swimsuit and I'm sexy dokey.
They called me up being like sexy dokey.
It's her time to shine.
They're cheering for you.
They all want to see you.
like me?
Me?
They're finally ready for the sexy?
They're finally ready for it?
Oh, wait.
Wait, wait.
Oh, you want my other form.
Is that it?
Dragons?
You want my other form?
My super sexy form?
Is that what you want, dragons?
is
that is that what you want my other sexy my sexier form no
please stay no what do you mean I've been telling the truth
this entire time one it's a swimsuit reveal two it's It's a
real swimsuit reveal.
Three.
This.
It's like hypnotizing, to be fair.
That's why.
Remember when I showed you that chat log?
I was like, I hope I don't get banned for this.
I...
Whoa.
Wow,
wow, wow, wow, wow, I can't...
Oh, wait, I forgot I could do this.
Am I sexy dragon?
My jingle jenga.
Yeah, this is my...
Jingle jenga.
Right here.
See it.
Oh my god, stop!
Look at the clouds are really beautiful today.
Anyway, okay, you guys want my sexier form?
Is that it?
Were you guys hoping to see my sexier form?
The jiggle is truly upsetting.
Logical.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I will actually pay you.
that again husky thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you don't worry i'm under the umbrella now i'm under
the umbrella so i can get untanned my my my my skin suit my
skin my skin cells repaired itself so now i'm i'm untanned
again that's what you mean right that's what is that what
you mean when you say you don't want to see that again um an
nsd thank you super chat thank you thank you all right all
right i shall now get into my sexier form give me a sec i
gotta oh my gosh it's been a while since i've done this so
give me a sec um okay all right
joki a bikini power
up Wait, how do I Wait, I'm still in the transformation
phase
One two Three Four 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, and 12.
Hello.
Is this a muscle dokey?
Is this better, dragons?
Is this sexier?
Oh, I should.
I hate it here Cyber, thank you For the Super Chat, thank
you That's right I'm finally A muscle mommy
That's right Let me
I'm so tall now.
It truly was a muscle girl, magical muscle girl
transformation.
I can crush, I sure can't crush things with more than just
my arms.
Neve.
Sekra, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
What is that?
What do you mean?
I'm a muscle doki.
I thought I'm a muscle doki.
you guys wanted the sexier the sexier form is that what you
want chat is that not what you want ha
can't see at zero hundred ten thank you the super chat thank
you thank you
it's okay it's okay i can transform back I could transform
back, guys.
It's like magical girl transformation.
I don't know.
Was that?
All right.
Is that not what you guys want?
No, go down faster.
No, no, no.
No, please.
What is it?
What's wrong?
You want me to be closer?
Oh, you want me to be closer.
I see.
Now, this, I'm a little worried about.
Okay, if the bot's gone, we know why.
If the bot is gone, we know why.
Get away.
Help.
Oh, my God.
I hope I don't get in trouble.
all right please please get away oh you get away there you
go is that better is that is that better wait is that better
are you what you like a close-up of This.
Oh, oh, yeah, I love my protein.
I sure do love proteins and getting those gains.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
11, 12, 30.
Oh, I gotta make sure I do my reps.
13, 14, 15, 16.
Now get those games, bro.
Do you like what you see?
Ha!
Anyway, happy April Fool's.
But there was no April Fool's here.
I told you though.
I told you everything that was going to happen.
I'm going to do a swimsuit reveal.
And not only did I do one swimsuit.
reveal I did two swimsuit reveal guys so it so I fed you
even I gave you a second meal I gave you a lunch a dinner
and a show I told you there was no April Fool's I gave you
exactly what I said I was gonna give you I delivered on my
promise I did not lie
I did not lie.
What do you mean?
The silhouette was real.
This fits perfectly into...
Here, let me show you guys.
Guys, let me show you guys.
This fit perfectly into the silhouette.
Approve it.
Give me a sec.
Approve it right here.
Where is it?
There you go.
Practically the same.
It's practically the same.
it's it's it's look at that it fits I wouldn't trust Tokyo
she told me the sky was a blue many thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you look at that it's practically the
same here um I said I was snake of faith but next time lied
to me better solid thank you with this super chat thank you
thank you look at that I told you guys I didn't about that
right I wish you was in a swimsuit and the monkey paw curls
yes because they gave you two swimsuits that's the monkey
paw curl you got two swimsuits saying thank you with a super
chat thank you thank you we were truly the fools of April
what do you mean I gave you fan service How is that a joke?
Muscle up!
Let me...
Guys, I gotta do my reps real quick.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
I'm changing back?
All right, don't worry.
Let me...
Oh, I keep flexing.
Oh, my God.
I can't help.
I can't help it.
want to chase those gains bro i just there's no stop
fan service for who what are you talking about look at all
those fans that have been serviced i keep no name thank you
oh wait thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
today's assume the worst.
What do you mean?
I thought I was sexy.
Oh, sorry.
Do you want this sexy?
Sorry.
Is this...
Here we go.
I'm sorry.
I need to give each of them equal amount of screen time for
the sexiness.
What do you mean?
I'm 10.
Look, see?
Look at that.
Pretty, pretty sexy.
I know all about sexiness.
I am sexy, dokey.
Don't make that sound.
If this is me, Fed, I'd rather be hungry.
Lego, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do you mean?
Like, you mean, under my umbrella.
Oh, yeah, here.
I do have...
Wait, alright, here you go.
Now I'm with all of you guys.
Hey, Chaydragoo, let's hang out.
You guys?
Chaydragoo, do you think I'm sexy?
I'll hang out with you.
Yeah, you want me to hang out?
You wanna... you wanna...
Hold hands?
Doki is going to have a swimsuit for real except it'll be a
Doki Koon in a swimsuit get away from me thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you how about you guys hey guys
you guys let's play together hey guys whoa Should I save
that dragoon from drowning?
Wow.
He's too cool to leave them below.
Don't worry.
Anyway.
I want to say huge shout out to...
Wait, let me pull up.
Huge shout out to new.
For those who don't know new, I will write...
This is actually the best swimsuit outfit reveal ever.
I am crying, Matt.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I want to say, I had no plans for April Fool's because
obviously I wanted to do the swimsuit reveal.
So I figured this would be the perfect way to reveal.
All right.
Okay.
serious serious two day two days ago i had zero plans for
april fools for april 1st and so but then i had this
brilliant idea of what if what if i do a swimsuit reveal i
because i was like you know what everyone is always fooling
others and tricking people and doing fake outs and
everything I'm gonna feed my dragoons today, you know, on
April 1st.
I'm gonna give them something that they actually want.
They...
I'm gonna give them something to look forward to.
And, oh, they look forward to it.
Stop.
I was like, you know what?
I want to give them something to look forward to on April
1st.
No fake outs.
No bait.
A real swimsuit.
And then they called me up.
Sexy dokey.
Chair.
This is so weird.
This day of my life.
Anyway, I want to give a huge shout out.
I pitched this idea to new.
For those who don't know, new pal has helped make, has
helped craft the skin suit for a dokey bug.
For, for dokefield amongst other.
And then now for sexy dokey and muscle, and sexier muscle.
so dokey in two days she made these skin suits one per day
so huge shout out for her to her for uh
for for how for um crafting these in two days what a trooper
insane yeah like honestly honestly it's insane that she was
able to do this in just two days and like putting up with my
crazy ideas that I get super last minute and being able to
craft the Mona Lisa of sexiness.
She really should have said no.
I, Chow, let me put up the text real quick.
The credits for all of you guys.
All right, let's see.
Sexy, jokie, new at.
I think that's her at.
I just gotta be sure.
Sometimes I'm wrong.
All right.
So huge shout out to her for basically making the Mona Lisa
of sexiness.
now, to make this all work, we had to play a little game.
Because obviously, I wanted to, you know, build up the
anticipation and the tension and play a little game of who's
that?
Doki bird!
Because there's so many dokeys in the dokeyverse now.
Oh yeah, by the way, here was like, here were like my
concept art for her.
I was like, Can you...
Alright, let me...
Sorry, I need to scroll back.
This is where the...
Because this is how I see how...
What I envision sexiness is.
So this is what's like the concept art I sent her to be
like...
I would like it to look sort of like this.
To embody like true...
True sexiness.
And I sent her this.
I was just like, this is how I see like what real sexiness
is.
And I drew the sexiest drawing in my head on MS Paint.
And I felt like it was very accurate to my vision.
It, I felt like it embodied my vision very well.
Uh, they got it so accurate.
I know.
Look, see?
Oh, yeah.
Ooh.
And then, after that, they sent me, like, whoops.
They sent me, uh, various, uh, concept art.
And I was just like, uh, there we go.
the concept art they sent me and i was like number three
obviously i was like oh my god look at those knockers on
number three damn oh my god and then they finished me sexy
dokey in just a day and i was like oh if you have time i
would love to get sexier dokey was number two i would love i
was like oh i would love to get sexier dokey if you have
time for on and they did they did let me and they did see
they did have time so huge shout out to anew for uh for for
um for crafting such a beautiful full arts of sexy uh anyway
back to back to me back to the the prime the origin
that mad lad she did it back to the origin um uh but i
wasn't satisfied i was like in needs to be bigger.
Whoops, sorry.
My bindings are all over the place.
I was like, it.
It needs to be bigger.
And what do you mean by bigger?
Well, I drew out a draft for her.
I was like, I want it to look like this.
When I say bigger, I mean bigger.
Then I was like, I don't want to be able to see my face for
I want to have I want to have an option to make it bigger
you put your tokeys away when your client goes with a bad
option clue just to show how good the other options were sim
thank you with a super chat thank you thank you this is the
greed they talk about guys and then for a bonus for those
who missed out she added wait where is it she added a little
slider for me so it's like character customization in like
the souls like games or mmos where you're just like whoa
whoa I can make it any size.
Oh, wait about this.
I just get it, right?
Right here.
All right, let's save that here.
Nice.
All right.
We'll just leave that here.
slide to the left slide to the right oh i almost forgot
you're still getting artwork with tab so this is a win
either way thank you for the super chat thank you thank oh
my god i almost forgot i almost forgot obviously you guys
want green screen right here
wait sorry
no we don't that's like oh don't worry i can pose for you a
pose and a pose and a pose oh yeah baby
that's right baby am i not sexy oh you want me to go for
sexy
You want a bigger?
Don't worry.
I got you.
Please stop posting.
All right, all right, all right, all right.
And then, there we go.
Out of this now.
There we go.
Yeah
That's right.
Okay, this is fine That's right.
I got to do my reps.
I get those gains bro and crush you with my thighs Look at
that.
All right, I'll get my good side by the way
That's right got my approach bars and my pro did you got did
you drink your protein shake today bro muscle girl
what's with the it's the it's the cup you know just so i
don't hurt myself just so like no one you know no one does
the pussy shot it's the it's the protection you know never
played hockey before before bro you fucking pussy but it's
dangerous you gotta take this true that's right that's
fucking right no i'm not canadian gotta protect gotta
protect yourself guys the Canadian is challenging us to
hockey
oh hmm hmm yeah it's beach hockey it's the newest craze
beach hockey exactly I know alright back to alright I think
you guys got all your screenshots, right?
Any request?
Any request chat?
Any request, anyone?
Sorry, this unrelated swimsuit, but did you know there's a
Canadian flying towards the moon right now?
I'm serious.
They just launched, yeah, and I threw that Canadian to the
moon.
That's right.
They called me to, like, they needed a shot-put expert.
And I threw them.
Suplex.
Appies.
Bro,
I'm flex-maxing right now, bro.
Bro, I'm flex-maxing right now, bro.
Too high.
Look at them go.
Bruno, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Let me...
hi all right let's go back to the beach everybody back to
the beach all right anyway so that was the creation of sexy
dokey um and then i had another idea like i said i was just
like how do i do the build-up to sexy dokey how do i
revealed this i can't just be like bam here it is you know i
gotta have like tension building up and um you know like
build up the anticipation of being like oh there it is there
she is
sorry let me be tan because i know that's sexier uh so let
me slide let me put the customization slider to the right so
you'll pay attention to me you know the jingle isn't this
what you want jingle jangle need to be like i'll be like all
right time to jingle jangle guys
oh where's the oh you're right god sorry um anyway so um i
was just like should play who's that dokey bird you know the
it's pikachu fun so i want a huge shout out to the three
artists who did all of this in a day for me um also shout
out to my go-to voice actor uh all right we'll see it kaitzu
um if you guys recognize the voice uh i usually get him to
do like random voice acting because they did the scooby-doo
they did the scooby-doo stuff for me stuff the the mr the
the SpongeBob episode uh and I got him to do who's that Doki
bird so huge shout out to kaitu my man I always go to them
for any voice acting thing um sorry not sexy Doki voice oh
my god fucking do it turn off that voice changer Doki turn
it down he's not good at voice holy shit uh shady thank you
for the akasupa thank you thank you nice physics bro love
the tan thank you i forgot to put the sunscreen on um um
voice acting kaitu and then i asked him i was like can you
get like a girl to also do because you know there is a uh
girl voice too and it's sad i don't remember her twitter
handle uh but she has done a lot she's done animations for
us And also, uh, she, uh, it's also a really good voice
actor.
Let me see, I can find her Twitter handle, where the hell is
going.
FF Sade.
So, huge shout out to Cade and Sade for the voice acting.
I'll give you guys, let's play, I'll let you guys play the
game again.
And I'll show each artwork individually.
Who's that dokeybird?
It's Dad.
It's Doakfield.
Mondays.
Who's that dokeybird?
It's Dokeybug.
Good job!
Who's that Doki Bird?
It's Doki Pride!
It's Doki!
Mow!
Who's that Doki Bird?
It's Dragoons!
Who's that dokey bird?
It's retro dokey.
It's not stealing if you're already dead.
Who's that dokey bird?
It's tomato dokey.
Yeah, so that, yeah, so that was all the dokey birds.
many there's more there was more donkeys in the dokey
version but then i was just like i had to split the the the
donkeys to three different artists because like i said i had
this crazy idea two days ago uh so huge shout out to my to
the artist and my edit video editor putting all of this down
and i didn't turn back go back go back
Is it a face?
Okay, how about if I talk like this?
It's just too sexy, right?
I'm so sorry.
I'm so, it's just way too sexy.
You can't function with how sexy that was.
You just got, you just, too distracted.
I understand.
I understand, guys.
I, anyway.
Anyway, so huge shout out to voice actor Kaito and Sane for
the Who's That Doki Brain?
Other than that, the artist, all right, the artist.
So you guys can see one by one who they were.
So shout out to Noah, let me grab her Twitter handle.
NPC Noah, and I'll show you guys which one she did.
Ooh, is that dokey bit?
Um, but um, but um, oh, I'm Tanya now.
I'll go hang out with my buddy here.
Who definitely wants to hang out with me.
Just hang out with my buddy.
Get away!
out with hang out with my friend will i show you guys the
doki's from the doki verse um all right first doki it was
very hard because the silhouette was obviously you know it's
like not you don't have as much freedom as the pokemon
silhouette uh with the dumb shit you can do for that so
there was a lot of creativity when it came to this so this
is all the ones that uh so above i'm so scared um dude what
oh did my wig flew off i'm sorry i picked it up let me um so
all right so here's the dragoon the dragoon version Oh my
god.
Look how tall you guys are.
Here's the dry wood.
Um, and then, let's see.
Where's the other one?
And then the other one is, um, here's Doakafield.
Here's Doakafield.
It fits though.
It fits the silhouette.
puberty hits you guys that's uh that's the lebron lebron of
dragons uh
and then of course i'm really good at risen hey hey goon is
that a is that a uh a baseball bat or are you just happy to
see me
and then there's dad beautiful
baseball fat and then a male jokie it's a huge shout out to
Noah for being able to make all of this in a day basically
Chonkun should see you for this Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please keep that face on.
I know because it's so hot.
I know.
Oh, are you an angel?
Did you fall from the sky?
Because you look like an angel from heaven.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So shout out to Noah for the beautiful, the beautiful
silhouettes that they drew of the...
Who's that donkey bear?
We don't claim that good donkey.
This freaking ninja shows up in my nightmares.
I'm suing you.
Oh, because it's just, it's just, it's just so hot, you
know, that of course I'll show up in your dreams.
anyway i just can't forget me you know i'm just in your head
24 7
all right next up pokey i hit her up at four in the morning
asking pokey pocums shout out to pokey i hit her up at four
in the morning and be like you think you're do this and then
she was like all right at first she got she was like i could
do four and then uh well four in the morning not like the
day of april fools obviously but it was like it was it was
like the two days before i hit her up at four in the morning
two days before and she's like yeah i could do four and then
and then she was like i think i could do two because she's
like this is a lot harder than i thought uh i was gonna do
two and i was like yeah that's cool Thank you for doing this
in the first place So she did Okay, let me change the text
Pokey Pokems She did Dokeybug and Crokey for me So there's
Dokeybug And then And then there's Crokey So shout out to
Pokey Be not afraid Why would you be afraid of me?
I'll have you know that I'm booked up all the way till 2028.
So, um...
Stand in line, boys and girls.
You gotta wane in line.
And you wanna hang out with me.
Bye, who?
Yeah.
winter thank you with a super chat thank you thank you when
she looks like an angel but it's a biblically accurate angel
the bag stays on thank you with a super chat thank you thank
you mister thank you with a super chat thank you thank you
you know i didn't ask for the face by the way this was like
um this was like a little well a little freebie from you so
you should say you knew she she was like we should add this
i was like oh my god you're a genius i
so it was a group effort it was a group effort
uh nimi eating good tonight guys lacrosse thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you all right and then the last
two would be from bear another friend of mine um i hit her
up the day before april fools asking if she could do this
and she was like yeah i can i'm in my i'm in i'm i'm in my
bathtub right now but yeah i'll do it after her after i'm
out i was like so huge shout out to ugly bear for um for
dough kitty and retro dokey so yeah they're all troopers for
doing this for for putting up with my crazy antics so
there's also a layer upon layers happy april fools you're
like oh my god dokey is next but which dokey
can you even have the one the dokey you wanted like when you
could have had dough kitty
I'm late but it looks like yesterday's stream was way more
risky than today Neppers thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you why can't this dough kitty be real um this
dough kitty is musical dough kitty there's layers and layers
to this can't even get dough kitty um and then also retro
and then we have retro doki as well so huge shout out to
agubert floor drying uh these two can't help it it's like
mesmerizing like i said it feels like i feel like i'm like
it's like so hypnotizing you know
eras thank you the super chat thank you thank you uh thank
you for having the silly idea and then them fabulously real
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you text the turkey thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you you're getting
very very sleepy very very sleepy
anyway anyway um and finally finally uh shout out to my
thumbnail editor slash wait, wait, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Slash video editor Hebe.
You guys might know Hebe.
She has done all my thumbnails and also sometimes bonus
edits when I do like outfit reveals and like any projects I
have that I need graphics for.
So Hebe, she that beautiful mind of hers that goddamn genius
I asked her to make a silhouette and she made her own
silhouette for me to use for who's that dokeybird so this
was all crafted by her since she has made my outfit reveal
thumbnails in the past so I've sent her lots of silhouettes
in the past so So, Hebe made the Who's That Doki Bird video,
and it looks so real, right?
And she crafted a silhouette of her own to help sell the
realness, because it was so real.
Of the silhouette.
So, shout out to Hebe.
made the video.
She also made the video for Who's That Dokey Bird?
And everything.
At first she had shoes on.
At first the silhouette had shoes on.
I was like, no, no, no.
To sell it even more for the ultimate bait, we gotta make
sure she has toes.
It's because we actually did the original silhouette.
The original silhouette, it was shoes.
I was like, no, she gotta have the toes.
out so people would be like oh my god like to sell the
realness of it to make it feel more real i was like you have
to have pose out there yeah because this this was the
original silhouette as you can see i was like no no no no it
doesn't feel real enough you have to have the the the
drippers out
and this was the edited version uh i'm sick and tired of
having eyes.
Kikura, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Next scene, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
Because it makes it feel more real.
I felt like it just has to be like, you know, got the
grippers, you know?
The perfect bait.
I was like, we're at a beach.
Who's weighing shoes at the beach?
Like, we gotta make it more realistic here.
I had I thought of everything I made sure to to no loose
ends, you know, no loose ends got to tie them all up
Everything was meticulously placed
And everything so yeah shout out to the team for the all the
amazing work they've done on making this a reality They did
all of this.
The entire team did all of this in two days.
Very much appreciated.
This was my...
Trusting you, devil, over.
Thank you, Doki Bean.
It's sexy, Doki.
AVI, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You never...
You just never expect what this mine can come up.
with what's going on in this mine and up there we have been
hoodwinked bamboozled led astray run amok and flat out
deceived how did i deceive you guys all i said was it's a
swimsuit reveal how is that lying a factor thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you i never said the silhouette
was for this swimsuit I know someone didn't read the terms
and conditions someone didn't read properly I never said the
silhouette was for this outfit I just said this it was a
swimsuit outfit
being abuzzled you didn't read the fine print guys I
everything I said was true.
So is it really an April 4th?
If we all got what we wanted?
I've spoken like a true politician.
I said it will be a swimsuit reveal.
And I gave you two swimsuit reveals.
Not just one.
It's like buy one, get one free.
See?
buy one get one free where it goes in her mind needs to
remain hidden thanks thank you for the magenta super thank
you thank you
look at that yeah what a deal you'll be hearing from my
lawyer cyber thank you for the super chat oh yeah member
goons look forward to tonight you'll be seeing one of these
skin suits while i draw
which one is the free version guys when i get my protein
protein shakes in i evolve
that's terrifying and this is the main the main the
headliner though buff joki my oh she will thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you welcome to tomato farm
welcome welcome jackie um turpish thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you my favorite so here about this
about how a great day you had today turpish thank you the
super chat thank you thank you thank you so shark thank you
for the thank you about the amazing time you had today and
how like everything you've ever dreamed of came true today
is that it
let me put the slider up
you're feeling very very sleepy very very sleepy
I love how it's just like a little, just so hypnotizing.
Could you not?
Jingle, jingle, jingle, jingle.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Mark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's how she enters your dream.
I'm like right here.
Like, what is that?
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
It's like Jaws.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
They're like, what's that in the distance?
Sure, like, they said the pool's closed.
But, like, it's some first day of summer vacation.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Ta-da-da!
Run!
Mark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm feeling very, very traumatized.
I'm suddenly an asthma.
Don't give me any ideas, Blake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's always next year.
why is it because i'm because i'm leaning forward what do
you mean
i don't have it for the skin suit too
the choke hold you i'm gonna talk oh my god stay back stay
back I heard you would a muscle mommy one two three four
five six seven eight anyway back to the main attraction
right here Anyways, after April 1st, a totally normal day
where everything you all wanted came true today.
Uh, never broke.
Everything you've ever dreamed of, everything, your hopes
and dreams and passion and expectations came true today on
the April 1st, where it was a totally normal day.
No fooling here.
No fooling.
Oh, I did fool you guys at the, in the beginning, right?
When the chat was different, the chat overlay was different,
guys.
Oh, I got you there.
Stop going back.
What do you mean?
This is not the perfect form.
I'm sexy dokey.
That's what it says on my resume.
On my Dokiverse file.
Two hours later and still on this.
I thought you guys want Jingle Jango.
Now whenever you ask for Jingle Jango, you know what's going
to happen.
You know what's going to happen now.
Xavier, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
all right all right i'll be nice there you guys go i'll be
nice for a bit because i was i've been slacking on these
games bro i drank my protein shake so i gotta make sure i'm
not slacking
Five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Oh, Daddy, so you guys see that, um, I'm sorry.
Do you guys see that, um, Sega announced the new Sonic
Collection?
I'm definitely going to buy a shirt, the Sonic Collection.
I don't know about where, I'll, I'll wear it in public.
I would actually wear that in public.
And it's not an ape.
That's so funny.
they released the um the sanic collection uh apparel
collection is literally sanic knuckles and who was it who
else was it it was uh let's see let me grab it oh it was uh
yeah it's sanic and knuckles so it's actually real now and
shadow okay yeah and shadow sorry i forgot
I actually want to I want I don't know I want all of them
they're all really good they're actually all really fucking
good I'm so tempted I'm actually uh I'm actually so tempted
to buy like the entire collection because it actually looks
real I would I would actually wear this I would wear this in
public it's a good shirt it's a good fucking shirt guys look
at this the satin collection.
I would...
I actually want to make my own collection where I just...
Emma's paint drawings.
I would buy the first two.
I wouldn't buy the third one.
I'm sorry, Naka's.
I'm sorry.
It just... I don't know.
It just...
It just doesn't hit as well as the first and the left one
and the middle one.
The right one, man, it's just... I'm sorry.
It's not you.
It just doesn't...
It's not as funny.
the other two bro that's sonic i think the first the left in
the middle one are really good don't really like the the
fire right oh but i i feel like japan loves um april fools
more than the rest of the world because they when when april
fools comes up for japan they go like all the way like even
the government is involved with april fools and wait are
they already sold no i should buy it when i saw it when i
saw it at 4 p.m yeah i i don't know why but it's like japan
japan loves it more than the rest of the world because in
japan like everyone does april fools stuff even like like
all the big like all the vtubers too in japan uh and and
like i think my favorite so far that out of the out out for
today I always okay back in the day when Kotaku wasn't like
a meme look there was a point when Kotaku was not a meme
okay guys they would have like a collection of like all the
April Fool's stuff all like in one article so I could just
go through them for the day and and just a little like
archive of all the April Fool's stuff they like the uh the
companies in japan did and anyway but now i use twitter for
that um anyway i think my first the i think my favorite part
my favorite april fools joke um from japan for this year was
the government releasing a uh the japanese government
released a dating sim and a dating sim that teaches bicycle
safety so i don't i think it's I don't know if it's a real
game you can play but it's basically all right so I'll send
the link for this yes so it's a dating sim where uh where
you're just where they're just like buff officers teaching
you about bicycle safety and um to be safe on the road so
anyway this is what it looks like
oh yeah oh it's just a video I hope I wish it was real
Anyway, the Japanese government did this.
It's the fact that it was the Japanese government.
Oh my god, I don't know if my...
Oh my god, you guys heard it.
But here, here's the video.
So, um, anyway, be safe, kids.
Make sure...
Oh, they got muscle.
So I thought that was really funny.
I think that one was my favorite.
Out of all the April Fool's stuff.
I mean, there were others.
But then, like, it doesn't hit as hard as the fucking
Japanese.
As your government.
As your government fucking.
Putting out a goddamn deal.
dating sim about bicycle safety um I mean I feel like dating
sim is so common too for like Japanese April Fool's because
I know like PAL World came out with like an actual playable
version of their um of their of the dating sim game that
they created that made as a joke last year and then kind of
Overwatch released one in the past Overwatch now for that
they did a thing where if you get deleted Winston during
they deleted Winston from Overwatch or their April Fool's
update because he's like oh he's going to a school reunion
at the lunar colony and map and then apparently if you get
the lunar colony map it's just all Winston's like you can't
pick anything else it's literally just all Winston's all the
time it's the only time you can play uh you can play Monkey
Wait, let me see, I can grab you guys the screenshot.
It's really funny.
I'll grab you guys the screenshot.
Oh, with the googly eyes, too.
I think that's the best part.
All wincens all the time.
All monkeying around.
All right, wait.
Where's that file?
I need to start cleaning up my fucking int there.
It's just all...
Oops, a Winston.
I thought that one was good, too.
It's just a Winston all the time.
Not enough.
Nine out of ten.
Not enough, Winston.
True, true.
I feel like they're short.
like one or two more Winston's there.
Also, this isn't an April Fool's joke, but apparently Star
Fox has more screen time than Rosalina in a movie about the
galaxy.
In a movie based off of a game that was entirely surrounding
about Rosalina's lore, apparently Star Fox has more screen
time than Rosalina.
Oh, Selena, that's my goat right there.
That's the joke.
That's the April Fool's.
That's all that.
For a Mario Galaxy movie.
Spoiler, by the way.
Don't spoil it.
Which part is the spoiler?
It's just screen time.
It's just, we all know, we all know he was in the movie, but
they already spoiled it.
He doesn't even go here.
Not even in the Mario universe.
Oh, good news though.
The audience loved the Mario, the Super Mario Galaxy movie.
That's actually a lot better news than...
that was a lot better news than the critical the reviewers
that gave it like you know that had like a 40% average
rating uh so at least that's better at least the crit you
know better than what the critics said but it has a 91%
rating right now on the first day so so at least that's you
know good news i got a little worried i got a little worried
there because some of the reviews were pretty bad they're
like it's worse than ai it's like there's no way it's worse
than ai he's like if i could have a pen to stab myself to
take me out of this agony i would i'm like what bro holy
this guy wants to stab himself because of how bad How he
doesn't want to sit through this movie no more.
And I'm like, oh my god.
He was willing to stab himself with a pen.
Any shit.
Um.
Oh, don't.
Well, I hope you guys have had.
A great April 1st, everybody.
I think I did.
I had a fun time.
Never stopped being a goober.
Always makes me laugh.
Thank you for the super chat.
McDonald.
Thank you for this.
Thank you.
Anyway, guys.
I do have another stream in two hours.
So I'll call it here.
But before I go.
I just got here and a pen thing sounds really accurate to
how I'm for real right now.
JK, this is how I keep doing it.
Thank you for the Aka Supa RW.
Oh, you didn't see this then.
You didn't.
If you just got here, don't worry.
I'll pose for you too.
Don't worry.
I hope you don't regret that Aka.
Ah.
Leave him alone.
Ward didn't see the main the main state, the main prize the
headliner.
Guys, they missed out.
They missed out on the jingle jingle headliner.
The main content.
The one everyone was waiting for.
Why did you speak?
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, guys.
Holy shit.
Play.
Thank you for the Aga Super.
Thank you.
Ooh, I can get a little naked for you if you want to.
That hard enough for you, baby.
Hey, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Don't worry, members.
There's more of this to come.
There's more of this.
There's more of this lady.
Remember goons.
Anyway, guys.
Where's the life god?
He's over there.
He's sleeping.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Move around.
Get up and...
move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.